all right everybody Rick giving
everybody a couple of minutes to come in
no it's not a clock on the last day so I
hope everyone's had their coffee
especially after last night yeah yeah
I'm not liking need a second cup all
right so let's get started shall we so
good morning thanks for everyone for
coming my name is Daniel chambers and
until recently I was a senior consultant
at ratify but recently in the last
couple weeks in fact this would be my
third week I started a new job at
Liberty Financial to help them along
their functional programming journey so
you might see why I had to change jobs
because my background is as a dotnet
developer starting it's starting in
c-sharp however over the last few years
I've become a little bit of a bit of a
functional programming nut I didn't
learn any functional programming at
university unfortunately so when I
learned F sharp it was a brand new
experience for me and then a couple of
years ago I got a fantastic opportunity
to write shipping production software in
Haskell and this opened my eyes to a
completely new way of writing software
and Haskell became my new favorite
programming language so hopefully today
I can impart to you some of the reasons
why I love writing code in Haskell and
why I think that more people should
consider to consider it as a viable
functional programming language so
developers we're human we're smart
creative ingenious people we like taking
complex problems breaking them down and
writing solutions for them we use
abstractions to help us manage the
increasing complexity of our software
problems we strive to do our best and be
constantly improving
however being human we also make
mistakes
we oversimplify we over complicate and
we miss edge cases and most importantly
we forget things there's nothing wrong
with this it's just a part of our human
nature and we're not blind to our
shortcomings we always create tools to
help us overcome our deficiencies we
created fire to keep us warm
whilst allow us to move around more
easily writing to allow us to remember
or beyond are fallible memories machines
to amplify our strength and make us more
productive electricity to power our
machines in our homes and of course most
recently computers to amplify our minds
the history of software development is
one of continual improvement the first
pieces of software that we wrote was
simple but now decades later the scale
and complexity of software far Dwarfs
anything that we've done in the past and
just like throughout history we managed
this through developing better tools to
allow us fallible humans to manage this
complexity we used to write code in roar
assembly but soon progressed onto high
level languages like C the abstractions
that structured programming introduced
allowed us to write more complex
software letting the tool take care of
some of the details and check our
thinking during the compilation process
soon after came C++ and more generally
object-oriented programming which
enabled greater complexity by giving us
the tools of encapsulation and
abstraction managed memory runtimes such
as the JVM and dotnet soon arrived to
take care of the complexity of memory
management and JavaScript once a simple
scripting language for the web has been
continually improved and fought with
sister languages like typescript adding
more tooling such as static typing to
help with managing complexity and
correctness even with this continual
improvement of our tools software and
software engineering as an industry
still has problems with managing
complexity and in particular ensuring
the software that we write is correct
there are so many industry jokes about
it but a recent xkcd comic that you may
have seen really highlighted it for me
when it compared software to other
disciplines with taking a stab at would
you really trust voting software with
your democracy and I think the answer
would probably be a resounding no
because of our really bad track record
at security change is a constant in our
industry and like the tide against the
cliffs over time it grinds our software
down into a broken broken buggy
unmanageable mess as developers we find
it difficult to safely modify our
software over time to adapt to changing
requirements while ensuring that it
still works
as intended we forget or fail to
recognize edge cases and we forget
sometimes why something was written the
way it was and we might not understand
code that someone else had written and
we know this so we employ more tools to
help us
compilers unit tests continuous
integration pipelines automated
deployments but let's not forget the
humble programming language a good
language should help us express our
intention clearly so that others can
understand it it should only allow us to
express our intention in a way that
minimizes mistakes and it should
wherever possible verify what we have
written is correct it should allow us to
think with precision never allowing us
to forget important edge cases I believe
functional programming and FP languages
especially Haskell are the next step in
our evolution of our language tools FP
can help us manage software complexity
resilience to change and quality
functional programming has become more
and more popular over time as mainstream
languages like C sharp C++ JavaScript
and Java all adopt functional
programming features and ideas more
fully functional languages like Haskell
F sharp and Scala are gaining popularity
as people recognize the advantages that
functional programming brings things
like functions as first-class objects
that allow us to more easily compose and
reuse code in ways that make sense a
declarative programming style that
allows us to lift our level of
abstraction up and focus on expressing
our business logic and not writing
plumbing code and purity and
immutability provide us guarantees that
allow us to write code that's more
testable and maintainable horrible
global mutable state is eliminated and
you can more easily reason about your
code when your functions are pure and
have no side effects and immutability
also gives us that double benefit of
making it easier to write concurrent
code that is correct and without race
conditions because it's not possible for
two threads to mutate the same state
haskell is a language that embodies
functional programming principles unlike
a language like F sharp or Scala which
straddle the fence between an
object-oriented language and a
functional one Haskell is a pure
functional language that epitomizes
functional ideals so let's take a tour
of Haskell's features that help us write
quality software that is correct
understandable and easily refactor able
so number one Haskell is a statically
typed language and this means that it
has a type system that is enforced and
checked by the compiler at compile time
people still debate dynamic versus
static languages but I think one only
needs to look at the JavaScript
ecosystem to see the value of a
statically typed language people have
literally had to make new statically
typed language that compile to
JavaScript such as typescript in order
to be able to manage larger and larger
JavaScript code bases dynamic typing can
be fine for small scripts throw away
prototypes and for quick coding but for
quality non-trivial software developers
need static types in order to help them
manage complexity jondor gos has
commented on Twitter that an
underpowered type system forces one to
program defensively and I think anyone
who's used a type system like C sharps
and Javas will know this feeling having
to do null checks and type tests is busy
work yet is easily forgotten and a
source of annoying bugs on the other
hand a powerful type system liberate s--
the developer to make changes with
confidence knowing that the type system
will validate his or her corrode code
for correctness John calls this fearless
programming Haskell has an extremely
powerful and strict type system as a
consequence Haskell forces you to write
code that is correct and rejects code
that is not now this might seem arduous
as you write code in comparison to a
dynamically typed language but what it
means is you actually spend far less
time debugging errors at runtime
it's somewhat of an in-joke that within
Haskell if it compiles it probably works
but I've actually found this to be the
case far more often than not one of the
annoyances of static typing can be
constantly having to tell the compiler
the type of what the type of things is
you write code if to repeat it over and
over thankfully Haskell has a very
powerful type inference engine that can
infer the types of your values and
functions by looking at the context of
what it is that you've actually written
so up on the slide we've got a function
called print error message and it takes
a message parameter and it prints to the
console
that message parameter and the error
value both have both been inferred to be
of type string and this is because the
compiler can figure that out by looking
at the context of where they've been
used so the message parameter is passed
to that string concatenation function
which is the plus plus operator and that
error is passed to put string line which
itself takes a string and the print
error message function itself is
inferred to return the type I O of unit
because that's what pure that puts stir
line returns however this type inference
can be a double-edged sword if your code
is not correct as you write it's the
compiler may infer incorrect types for
things which can make compiler error
message is much harder to understand
because it'll be telling you about types
that you didn't actually intend to write
but it's also much harder to understand
code when the types aren't there and
everything's inferred good naming of
variables can help carry you for a while
but nothing beats a good type to
describe exactly what something is other
languages like F sharp will try to try
to resolve this issue through tooling so
if you use the vs code extension ioan
I'd in F sharp it'll display the type
signature for functions above them in
line in the code to help you understand
the code as you're reading it however
this doesn't help you when you're
reviewing code in another editor or in
github in a PR for example haskell
solves these issues by allowing people
to explicitly add type signatures to
functions and this helps resolves the
issue of when you're writing code and
you've got a little bit wrong and type
inference is messing up your compiler
error messages because the incorrect
types are slipping in so you start
writing a function by defining its
desired type signature and then as you
write the function the compiler can help
you fill in the blanks using type
inference and this actually changes the
way you write code whereby you let the
compiler guide you by looking at the
error messages that it gives you back to
determine what you need to do next in
your function to satisfy the type
signature that you started with by
having that type signature actually in
the code it also means you can read the
code directly on github or and any any
editor that you like and still be able
to see these types images because
they're just texting
for me after having this it's going back
and reading f-sharp code is a bit harder
because I can't see the type of
functions when I viewed the code on
github in Haskell type signatures are
just there for me to read and because
they're written separately above the
function
it keeps the actual code clean and
concise without cluttering it with type
information the type signatures also act
as documentation for a function so you
can very often look at a function and
tell what it does and how to use it
simply by inspecting its type signature
so we can see that the print error
message function does IO because it
returns the IO type another good example
is the function zip and that's type
signatures up in the slide in the bottom
by reading that type of signature we can
see that it takes a list of a's and the
list is the the square bracket syntax
and it takes a list of b's so it takes
two parameters and it will return a list
of a b pairs that's a tuple of a and B
we can intuit that this means that it
combines those two lists together and
produces a single list of the elements
paired together and we can tell that
just by looking at the types the a's and
b's there are generic types so this
function could be used with a list of
string there's in a list of intz for
example and it would return a list of
string end pairs this descriptiveness of
the type system provides unexpected
benefits so the Haskell eco system has a
search engine called Google which allows
you to search for functions by their
type signatures so let's try an example
imagine we want a function that takes a
list transforms each element and then
also filters the list at the same time
so you can think about it as a where and
a select together f-sharp people might
recognize that as a choose function but
if we're new to Haskell we might not
know what it's actually called in the
Haskell standard libraries and this is
where who will can come in and help us
we can write out the type signature for
that function so the first parameter is
a function itself that transforms each
element a into a B and can optionally
discard it and that's where that may be
type comes in so maybe we'll keep it the
B or not the second parameter is an
input list of A's and the return type is
a list of transformed and filtered B
so when I put that type of signature
into Google it immediately returns a set
of matching functions and right at the
top is the one that I want which is the
map maybe function from the data maybe
module that's pretty cool
so huugle is incredibly useful to see
whether there's a function out there
that does what you need rather than you
implementing it yourself a lot of the
time you're just able to pull on a
library that does what you want and it's
also super useful when you're learning
and you don't know where all the basic
functions are you can just ask huugle I
need a function that does this type it's
type signature in and it'll give you a
list of matching functions and it does a
fuzzy match as well so if you don't get
it quite right it might find you one
that's close another static typing
feature that Haskell offers is to help
you write an understandable and correct
code is something called a some type a
some type is a type that expresses a
fixed set of alternatives so another way
of saying this is that a sum type allows
you to make a choice between different
things so you can define an explicit
choice between a B and C a typical
example is modeling the presence or
absence of a value so Haskell does this
with the maybe type which can either be
just with a value or nothing without a
value so the syntax is up on the slide
is saying that we have a data type
called maybe it has a generic parameter
that we're calling a and it can either
be a value called just that has contains
a value of whatever the type a is or it
can be a value called nothing which
doesn't have anything associated with it
so when we have a maybe value we can use
Haskell pattern matching syntax which is
that case of syntax to see whether then
maybe we have at hand is actually a just
or nothing and then do something
different in each case that may be type
is actually built into the Haskell base
library so you don't need to write it
yourself but that's pretty much all it
is the either some type is also built in
and it offers the ability to model a
choice between two different values so
we can either be a left which can
contain whatever type a is or right
which can contain whatever type B is the
either some type is often used to model
error handling so for example either
error int is a type that could either be
left with
era or right with an INT of course you
can define your own some types to model
alternatives in your domain accurately
so for example we could make an arrow
type that models the different areas
that we get when we validate a file path
so it could exceed the max length of a
path and we could pass along the the
actual length that it that it was it
could use invalid characters and we
could also pass along the length of the
invalid characters that it did use or it
could just be an empty string well we
don't really need to put a new
associated data with it we could then
write up PA's file path function that
takes that string validates it and then
returns either a path validation or a
valid file path and that's what the type
signature up on the slide is is saying
so a typical way of writing code like
this in a language like C sharp might be
to use exceptions we've probably all
seen a method similar to this at some
point where you've got you pass a string
to this validate file path method and it
will either just do nothing or throw an
exception with probably the error inside
that exception type now unfortunately
with that sort of form we have no way of
knowing what sort of errors to expect
from that validate file path method
without reading its implementation or
perhaps its documentation the type
signature there doesn't mention the
exception at all that could be thrown so
we can see how some types can be used to
make error handling explicit and indeed
can be used to make any alternatives in
your code explicit in the types and this
is also useful when you change your code
so if you add an alternative to a some
type the compiler will tell you all the
places in your code that you need to
update to account for that new
alternative and it will do that through
a compiler warnings and typically that's
one of the compiler warnings you turn
into an error so this is a really good
example of how Haskell helps you
refactor your code safely because you
can go and modify these some types in
the future and the compiler will tell
you all the places that you need to
update
in fact through the use of some types
Haskell eliminates that annoying
non-reference exception that we get in
languages like C sharp and JavaScript in
c-sharp any reference type can be null
in Haskell null isn't a thing at all it
doesn't even exist if you need to model
the potential absence of something then
you use the maybe type and this means in
Haskell you opt into null ability if you
try to pass and maybe to a function that
doesn't take a maybe you get a type
error so the compiler won't let you do
it if a function returns a maybe and you
don't deal with it then you get a
compile error so this contrasts against
the languages like C sharp where you
have you have opt-out null ability and
you have to end up doing busy work and
error-prone coding such as checking for
unexpected nulls and throwing exceptions
to work around it the compiler doesn't
stop you from passing null where you
shouldn't and you find out at runtime
with a crash if you call a function and
you get back a null but you don't code
for it then you get a crash at runtime
have a look at the a school and c-sharp
list find type signatures up on the
slide in the high school version of find
it's impossible to pass maybes to that
function because it doesn't take maybes
and you explicitly get back and maybe to
represent if you weren't able to find
whatever it was you were looking for in
that list you can't get it the contents
of that may be unless you do a pattern
match so you know you literally have to
handle the case where you didn't find
something the language forces you to do
it in the C sharp version you can pass
null for that predicate and you'll get
an argument null reference sorry an
argument null exception at runtime you
can also get back null from that
function and unless you explicitly check
for null being returned you could get a
null reference exception so this is just
one of the many ways that Haskell uses
its strict and powerful static type
system to ensure that you're writing
correct and bug-free code by making such
concepts explicit in the types
developers can clearly understand the
implications and the edge cases of using
functions which means that they can
write and refactor code more safely and
confidently
another powerful feature of using the
Haskell static type system is the
ability to find new types a new type is
a data type that simply wraps an
existing type and this is useful when
you want to add new meaning to an
existing type so a good example is an
email address an email address is just a
string but it's not just any string it's
a string that must match a certain
format so you can define a new type
called email address that wraps the
string and then you can pass around
email address instead and this means
that you can write a validation function
that takes a normal string and checks if
it's a valid email address and then
returns either an error or a valid
wrapped email address so that pars a
mail address type signature on the slide
is an example of what that might look
like
once you've got a valid wrapped email
address you can pass that around and use
it safely in all subsequent code the
compiler prevents you from passing a
string to a function that expects an
email address because a string and an
email address are not the same type the
email address is a new type code that
takes an email address can know that it
doesn't need to deal with invalid email
addresses which simplifies the code and
helps eliminate bugs it also makes your
type signatures file or more descriptive
which helps the understandability of the
code so have a look at the send email
type signature and this is kind of an
extreme example but you can see that it
takes an email address a subject and a
body just from the types if this was
just a string string string
that'd be far less useful we can't
accidentally pass a body where the
subject would go or vice versa that
would be a compiler over because subject
and body are at the same time and the
best thing about new types in Haskell is
that they're cost free at runtime the
compiler after type checking will
actually substitute the unwrapped type
so there are no extra memory allocations
needed for that wrapper type at all and
this is unlike in other languages where
a wrapper types often have a runtime
performance in memory penalty so here's
a practical example of where new types
can help improve code clarity on a pass
gig I saw some code in a class that
talked to an API that deals with some
IOT devices the developer who wrote the
code made a responsive
tea class to represent either some error
of return sorry some data that's
returned by that API call so that would
be whatever the T is or an error if in a
string if that if something happened to
that API call he had some methods that
call that that backing API so I put the
type signature for a couple of them up
there
one was called get devices and it
returns a responsive string it turns out
that string was actually the entire
jason body of the HTTP response he also
had get device serial which got the
serial number of a device given a
particular ID but it also returned a
responsive string except in this case
the string was a serial number so
straight away we can see some issues
with this code right both methods
ostensibly return the same thing but
it's not really the same thing and it's
hard to tell what they actually return
without looking the implement at the
implementation of those methods the
response type also doesn't stop you from
having a null data or an error or even
both data or error being said at the
same time in c-sharp to create a wrapper
type around those strings to distinguish
between adjacent string and a device
serial you need to create a new class
but this is kind of ugly because it
incurs an extra memory allocation that
value that value property could still be
null and you can't compare that type for
quality like you can the string so you
can fix all those issues but it requires
lines and lines of tedious and
error-prone code in high school this is
a non-issue we can simply create cost
free new type wrappers for all of those
types and we can use the either type to
to model that alternative between a
success and a failure we could even
create a some type for the error to
explicitly describe the set of errors
that we expect rather than just using a
string so straight away it's now clear
what our functions take and what they
return so we can see where our get
devices we can tell that it does some IO
because there's an IO type and it can
return either an error or a JSON string
and then when we look at the get device
serial we can see that it takes a device
ID and it does some IO and will return
either an error or a device serial so I
can look at those immediately know what
I need to pass them and I know what
turn so again Haskell is helping us
right understandable and correct code
through its strict and expressive static
type system so variables variables are
moving parts in our code and we know
that undisciplined use of variables can
result in code that's very difficult to
reason about and therefore get correct
and bug free and maintained into the
future working with immutable data
structures can simplify code by removing
those moving parts in our code the
variables it's not that immutable data
structures don't change it's a it's just
that they operate on a copy-on-write
basis so modifying an immutable data
structure results in new copy being
created that incorporates those
modifications and this isn't necessarily
as inefficient as it sounds as many data
structures immutable data structures
will reuse a large part of the old data
structure in the new version so for
example a Haskell list is a singly
linked list so adding a new element to
the list simply means adding a new node
to the front of the existing data
structure and as you can see up on the
slide list a hasn't changed at all but
list B includes lists as nodes inside
itself all data types in Haskell are
immutable it's not possible to create
mutable data types in Haskell at all and
this guarantee takes a lot of complexity
and unknowns out of your code
immediately you never need to worry
about whether a type might be mutable
and therefore whether you need to worry
about it being mutated or unexpectedly
if I pass a data structure to a function
it is a hundred percent guaranteed that
that function can't mess with it if I
pass a list to a method in c-sharp for
example I don't get a guarantee that
that method isn't going to modify the
list or it might even modify something
inside the list in Haskell as a function
author if I I know that if I'm past
something I can safely use it without
worrying that something else that I
don't know about perhaps on another
thread might change that thing that I
have I don't have to check that
assumption in high school it's a
guarantee
so Haskell has language features that
make it really easy to work with
immutable data structures so up on the
slide I've defined a Haskell record type
called book
contains title and author fields we can
then define a function called change
title that takes a new title and an old
book and creates a new book based on the
old book and just changes the title on
it so Haskell will take care of copying
all the other fields on that on that
book such as the author forests and that
works even if there are more fields
there so if we had 10 extra fields on
that book record type that change title
code wouldn't change it wouldn't change
at all it would stay the same and the
compiler would just behind the scenes
copy those extra fields for us and this
is in stark contrast to languages like C
sharp well we're working and creating
immutable data structures is extremely
tedious you need to create a class with
read only properties you need a
constructor that'll take all the values
and set the properties and you need to
write methods to manually do that
copy-on-write it's so painful it's not
surprising that nobody does it functions
take input and they return output a pure
function is one that does no
side-effects and that when given the
same input will always deterministically
return the same output impure functions
are harder to maintain and reason about
because they depend upon shared state so
in order to think about what an impure
function does you have to kind of expand
your mind to encompass every other piece
of code that modifies that shared state
with it as well as that impure function
that you're trying to understand at hand
pure functions by contrast can be viewed
and understood entirely in isolation
their type signatures give a very strong
signal as to what they do which is
really nice when it comes to
maintainability because I don't need to
dive into implementations to see what
something does you can just look at the
types of a pure function and go oh yeah
I kind of see what that thing does and
there's no fear that they might be doing
might be doing some invisible
side-effects in its implementation that
you actually do need to know about so if
we look at that map function type
signature up in the slide which we've
seen before but you might recognize it
as select from C sharp we can see that
we give it a function that converts an A
into a B and we can and we also give it
a list of A's and it will return back to
us a list
B's so the a and B here abstract and
that's like generics in c-sharp or Java
there's no typecasting in Haskell so
when a function receives an abstract
type like an A or a B it literally can
do nothing with it at all because it
doesn't know what it doesn't know what
it is - it is just this is an a I don't
know anything more about it in this case
the map function can do nothing with an
A or a B except for one thing it can
convert an A into a B and that's only
because it was given a function that can
convert an A into a B so as someone
looking at this function you know that
there cannot be any black magic going on
inside this function at all that could
bite you because all data types are
immutable in Haskell you know the list
that this produces must be a new list
and that original list that you pass it
will remain untouched you don't need to
check the documentation or the
implementation to know this and this
strictness gives you confidence as a
developer to know what a function can do
without checking its implementation for
unexpected behavior it means you can
write and refactor code with confidence
this is in contrast to other less strict
FP languages like F sharp for example if
I see a function in F sharp there's no
guarantee that that function doesn't
modify some static variable or mutated
cinput parameters or perform any other
side effect inside itself now it's good
practice in F sharp to not do that and
to work with immutable data types
but because mutability and impurity are
allowed in the language you don't have
that absolute guarantee like you do in
haskell you lose a level of trust and
you have to spend a bit more time
checking your assumptions so for example
look at the F sharp version of the
change title function up on the slide I
can see that it takes a new title and an
existing book and it returns a book but
unless I check that book is actually in
a mutable type I've no guarantee that
this function is actually a pure so for
example book might be a mutable class
type and change title might be mutating
that input book and returning it now
this would be very poor form an F sharp
and if I found it in a PR that PR would
be sent back and you would have to
change that to an immutable immutable
type but in F sharp it is possible so
you lose that level of trust
in Haskell this is impossible because
mutability doesn't exist so Haskell's
restrictions of requiring immutability
and purity actually benefit the
developer by ensuring that he or she can
make safe assumptions about how code
works immutability and pure functions
also aid us and writing testable code so
pure functions are naturally testable
because they don't have any side effects
if you give a few if you give a pure
function the same input it will always
deterministically return the same output
which makes it super-easy to test you
just pass your input and assert that it
returns what you expect pretty simple as
a contrast in pure code that has side
effects either can't be tested or it
must have those side effects mock down
and carefully managed resulting in
complex and fragile tests pure code is
also very easy to make concurrent the
biggest issue with writing concurrent
code is dealing with race conditions
where two threads will modify the shared
state in unexpected ways and in
unexpected times because pure code only
works with immutable datatypes it's
impossible for multiple threads running
pure code to interfere with each other
since because this mutable state just
doesn't exist so Haskell's purity
guarantee that means you can trust that
any pure functions are safe to use in
concurrent parts of your application
they can't modify any shared state by
definition which means that you know for
sure that whole classes of race
conditions are just not possible you
don't need to check you can just use it
and it works this is another haskell
guarantee that gives you confidence that
you're writing correct code so purity is
all well and good but your programs kind
of useless unless it can actually do
some side-effects and affect the real
world
so if Haskell so pure how do we manage
impurity so a function for getting the
current time is a good simple example on
the slide up at the top there's a
function that takes unit which is a bit
like void and it returns the current
time however that function is actually
impossible in high school since for that
function to return a different UTC time
each time it's called with the same
input to the same void like unit it
would have to violate purity
because pure functions must be
deterministic given the same input they
must return the same output so given the
same unit I get a different time every
time I call it so this is where Pascal's
IO monad comes in the IO monad allows us
to write impure code in a pure way so to
get our current time our get current
time function would probably look more
like that it would return an IO of UTC
time and in fact because of purity this
function would always have to return the
same IO of UTC time anyway because given
the same input must return the same
output so we can just drop that input
parameter and just have a value instead
of a function and the value is of type
IO
of UTC time so how can we use this well
let's write something simple that
calculates the current time and adds 10
seconds to it to do this we can use the
bind operator which kind of allows us to
hook a function up that receives the
value inside the IO so here we're using
a lambda function and that's
what--that's slash in arrow syntaxes and
that lambda function will take the
current time out of the IO and then add
10 seconds to it this lambda function
itself is still pure code given the same
time it will always return the same
value the IO type in the signature is a
big signal to the developer that there's
some impure stuff going on inside this
code which is a big bonus for code
readability
now these io values are just potential
values to actually run them and see them
to i/o you actually have to hook them up
to the real worlds and we can do this by
hooking them up to the programs main
entry point so in the case up on the
slide we've got a little program that
reads the current time adds 10 seconds
to it and then prints that to the
console and quits so we can now affect
the real world by using the IO monad
however this doesn't mean we want to do
our entire program inside of IO what we
want to achieve is the majority of our
code to be written outside of IO in a
pure fashion and then we connect its
edges up to the real world with a little
bit of IO so in other words we want to
push IO to the edges of our application
and this makes our code a lot easier to
test and reason about
so here's a micro example of how we
could cut up that previous code that we
wrote in order to keep the obits
separate from the actual program logic
so notice how we've pulled out that pure
lambda into a separate function we can
test and reason about that more easily
now seeing the IO type on functions and
values is an instant indication that
there's some sort of side effect going
on inside that code and this makes the
division between impure and pure code
very obvious and never a nasty surprise
to the developer and this is important
when writing new code or refactoring
existing code because you can
immediately start thinking about all the
additional complexities that side effect
of all code introduces and be wary on
the flip side not seeing io means you
don't need to think about those
complexities at all so you have that
level of trust
Haskell makes it very very easy to get
value semantics for your data types
now valley semantics is where the
identity of an object is determined by
its value rather than by the particular
instance of the object in memory so for
example instance strings in c-sharp have
value semantics I can have the same
string two instances in memory and if I
say equals they'll be considered to be
equal but by default classes in c-sharp
have reference to quality so if I knew
up this the same class that have the
same properties on it unless I override
equals and I say if these are equal
LeBeau no because these are two
different objects in memory so when
types are mutable value semantics can be
tricky because equality results can
change as the instance mutates but since
everything in Haskell is immutable it's
very easy to start using value semantics
in fact usually all you need to do is
ask the compiler to derive the EQ type
class on your type and you've got
equality for free have you ever tried to
write a test where you need to compare a
list of objects or nested object graphs
this is super painful to do without
value semantics you have to compare each
list element individually typically in a
loop and then compare each property
individually with your assertion library
wouldn't be better if you could just
construct the expected result and just
go equals well in Haskell you can so we
could write a unit test that
for example gets a list of transactions
and simply does a comparison between the
expected list and the actual list using
equals and that's all this should be
function is doing under the covers
it just doesn't equals and the other
stuff that it does is if it is not
equals it prints out nice things on your
test runner lists in Haskell are also
equatable so long as what they contain
is equatable so in this case our
transaction data type is equatable
because we derived a queue on it so the
lists are also naturally equatable as
well which means that we can just do
should be on the two lists and it works
so compare how easy this was to achieve
versus how you'd need to do it in F
sharp or C sharp well in F sharp it's
actually easy even in C sharp it's a bit
more painful so in C sharp if we wanted
to implement value semantics you'd need
to implement equals yourself and you
need to do it for each of your types and
you need to compare each property on the
type by hand and if you added a new
property later you'd better remember to
update your equals implementation or
you've got a subtle bug in highschool
the compiler takes care of it for you
ensuring that you can easily modify your
code with confidence into the future so
if I went and added and say in the
future description to my transaction I
wouldn't have to change anything except
I'd have to modify that test so the
compiler would catch me there because
I'm creating transactions are not
sending the description so property
testing is another thing that's really
easy to do in high school especially
with value semantics being so easily
doable so probably testing is where you
can have your test framework generate
random input values and then you write a
test to check whether your code works in
a certain way for all the generated
input values so in other words for all
inputs a certain property holds for your
code under test so the textbook example
of this is if you're writing tests for a
list reversing function so a property of
reversing a list is if you reverse a
list twice you get back what you started
so this property holds no matter what
type of list you give the reverse
function so you can see in the code up
on the slide we're passing a lambda
function to the to the
tests the test framework we'll call our
lambda function over and over and over
and it will pass in empty lists it'll
pass in lists was one things in them it
will pass the list with two things this
were ten things and it will do that a
number of times and we ascertain our
test that the input list is the same as
reversing the list twice now if any
input causes that assertion to fail then
our property test fails properties are
particular to your domain so imagine an
our domain we could say that all
invoices must generate at least two
transactions we could write a property
test that generates random invoices and
checks that our transaction list length
is always greater than or equal to two
so property testing is a great way to
ensure that you're writing correct code
that stays correct as you change it over
time Highschool is a lazy evaluation
language as opposed to the strict
evaluation languages that we'd normally
use this means that you can write code
in a way that appears to be inefficient
from a strict language point of view but
since high school only evaluates what's
necessary when it's actually required
your code executes sufficiently anyway
laziness helps you subtly all over the
place when you're writing high school so
to demonstrate laziness on this slide
we're going to use the from maybe
function and let's see how that function
works before we use it so from maybe
we'll take a maybe value and a fallback
value and if the maybe exists then it'll
just return what's inside the maybe so
if it's just it returns it but if it's
nothing then it returns your fallback
value so for example here where we pass
just something we get back something but
if we pass nothing then we get back our
fallback value so you can think of it a
bit like a null coalesce in c-sharp now
let's see how laziness kicks in when we
look at the code at the bottom of the
slide in a strict language that
expensive value would be evaluated
before it's passed to from maybe so we'd
pay the costs of calculating that
fallback value even though it wasn't
necessarily going to be used in high
school expressions are only evaluated
when their value is actually required so
the millionth prime that we're
calculating here is the fallback value
would only be calculated
if there maybe was nothing if there
maybe was just then we don't need that
fallback value so it will never be
calculated here's another example
imagine we're transforming each item in
the big list with an expensive
calculation so that weird dollar symbol
is map so like select in NC shop now we
only want the 101st of 150 lament from
that list we want to drop the first 100
and take the next 5 in a strict language
if we wrote it this way we'd be paying
that expensive transform costs for those
first at least the first 100 list
elements the ones that were dropping on
the floor before we get to the five that
we actually want however in Haskell
laziness ensures that that transform
will only be done when required so when
we eventually look at the five elements
that we've picked out of the list the
transform will be done then and only on
those five elements the hundred that we
dropped and just lost that will never do
that transform on them laziness means
that you can write code more
declaratively in a way that makes makes
sense it reads more cleanly and only the
parts that are actually needed are
actually run however laziness is a
double-edged sword you get those
execution efficiencies but you can also
get cut by a new type of memory leaf
called a space lick and this is where
because of laziness you may retain
things in memory longer than you expect
because the code that would otherwise
decide to drop that memory hasn't
actually run yet so on a pass Haskell
project that I worked on we had an issue
where we loaded a whole bunch of jobs
out of a CSV data source and we put them
into a map so that we could look them up
easily
now each CSV row that we had would
contain far more information than we
actually needed it was quite a big CSV
so we only stored the few columns that
we actually cared about in our job
record type which you can see up on the
slide however when we ran this thing our
program used a lot of memory for no
apparent reason even though we were
keeping only a few fields from each row
and you can see the chart the Haskell
memory profiler generated for us up on
the slides we used a lot of memory and
we're like what so what was actually
happening was that each CSV row was
being read in form M
read into memory for pausing however
when we set the properties on those on
those records such as job ID the actual
pausing of that row in memory to get
those fields out of the row in memory
was lazy
so until we actually needed the values
of the properties on the job record that
pausing wasn't being done because it was
lazy and therefore the memory holding
what was going to be paused was kept
around so effectively it did the
opposite of what we wanted and loaded
the entire CSV into memory until we
looked at the jobs and then it went oh
you actually want to know what the
advertiser ID is cool I'll do the
pausing now and here's your advertiser
ID so we fixed this by forcing
strictness on each job as we created it
so there is a way in highschool to say
no no actually run this now please and
that of course forced the evaluation of
the parsing logic which now complete
drops the CSV row from memory during
garbage collection because we don't need
it anymore
and as you can see we went from over a
gigabyte of memory usage down to about
180 Meg which is much more like what we
expected now in my mind space licks are
the biggest downside of high school
laziness while useful pretty much all
the time in high school sometimes also
makes it harder to reason about the
execution time and the memory usage of
your code so you need to keep an eye on
it so you aren't in for any surprises
when you're dealing with a large data
set or high load however I think it's
fair to say that for any application
that will experience high load or will
be using a very large data set you
should probably always be testing it
under that load or with that large data
set so that that requirement shouldn't
be an unusual burden but it is something
to keep an eye on when you're writing
high school so developers these days are
excited about various language and
runtimes that allow them to do
asynchronous and concurrent programming
more easily
traditionally threading and concurrency
has been quite difficult to manage by
hand so C sharps async/await nodejs is a
non-blocking i/o and go Lang's
lightweight go routines have gotten
developers quite rightly salivating
Haskell also has a very elegant and
powerful handling of asynchrony and
concurrency so high scores of runtime
uses a lightweight threading
which means that you can spin spin up
and use very like loads and loads of
threads with very little overhead all IO
operations in Haskell are non blocking
by default in that they don't block an
OS thread and this means Haskell is
asynchronous by default however Haskell
does give you explicit control over when
you go concurrent and when you don't so
for example that read from web services
function up on the slide is asynchronous
in that we get each web respond each get
web response call doesn't block an OS
thread however that function doesn't
perform those those requests in parallel
it does them sequentially if you want to
go parallel you can ask the Haskell
runtime to perform that IO concurrently
and that's what we're doing in red from
Web Services in parallel the simple
change there is to just pass each i/o
operation which is the get web response
a and get web response b2 concurrently
and then concurrently will execute those
two things in parallel and will get the
response back ice cores libraries offer
many different functions that make doing
things concurrently simple such as like
a function that will take a list of i/o
operations and run them all in parallel
though Haskell can expose to you its
underlying threading model most of the
time you just work with these high-level
constructs this means you usually don't
mess around the threads yourself instead
you just work with concurrency functions
and a kind of async/await style of
coding and you let the runtime figure
out how to schedule all that stuff the
best on your multiple cores and of
course because there's no mutability in
high school writing concurrent code is
much easier so most statically typed
languages these days support the concept
of generics or type of parameterization
generic code is extremely useful for
expressing abstractions that don't care
about the types used within them so for
example a list of T where T can be any
type at all Haskell's type system takes
us one step further by supporting a
feature called higher kind of types now
you can think of kinds of a way of
expressing types of types so types
without generics are just types but once
you introduce generics you change the
kind of a type to be
a type function so a type that takes
another type and returns a type just
like a function takes a value and
returns a value and this is why the
maybe type has a kind of type arrow type
because it's actually a type function
that takes a type and returns a type so
if you call the maybe type by just
giving it another type so like if we
write maybe int then you've actually
invoked a type function and you've made
a type that's maybe specialized two intz
higher kind of types is where you can
write generic code where the generic
type parameters can be higher kind so
for example type arrow type or type
arrow type arrow type and so on and you
can see an example up on the slide that
the map function is generic over a type
called
F whose kind is type arrow type and we
can tell what kind is that because we
can see F has been passed a and F has
been passed B so it must be a type
function now this isn't possible in
something like dotnet unfortunately and
you can see where I've tried to write
what it might look like in c-sharp but
you can't do that that will obviously be
a compile error but it is possible in a
language like Haskell so type classes
are another Haskell feature that when
used with higher coded types allow us to
write some extremely powerful
abstractions these abstractions make our
code far less noisy and allow for high
levels of code reuse
don't confuse type classes with oo
classes just because it has the word
class in there type classes are more
like traits if you've ever used a
language that has traits and maybe you
could stretch it and say they're a
little bit like interfaces so let's see
one in action we can define a type class
called a functor that has a higher kind
of type called F and defines a single
function called map which we've seen a
number of times now so just think select
in your head so we can create an
instance of this type class for the
maybe type and so that means when we use
the map function on Maeby's the compiler
knows oh I know how to implement functor
for Maeby's and i go here and this is
where my map function is defined so you
can see on the right hand of this of the
slide where we're passing an inter
string function to the map along with a
maybe to convert the in
that might be inside the maybe into a
string if it's their honor if we
substitute the concrete types into the
map type signature so that's the Green
Line we can see that a has is now int B
is string and F is may be and we can
implement functor for many more types so
for example list and i/o and we can use
map in exactly the same way so you can
see in each of those in the green type
signatures the only thing that's
different is that F is list and i/o
respectively
and this is very powerful because what
it means is that we can write a function
that works for any functor so for
example we could make an inter string
any functor version of those functions
that works for any functor we give it
and we can see in the type of signature
that we've basically pinned int and
string but we've left F to be abstract
and we're saying that F must be a
functor so type classes let us write
functions that are abstract over types
and therefore get really good code
reusability it also means that when I
look at a function like inter string any
functor I have confidence that the only
thing that it can do with that F type is
use the map function on it because the
only thing it knows about F is that F is
a function and a functor can do map this
means that I can trust that if I pass
the list it's not going to mess with
that list in an unexpected way the only
thing they can do with it is do a map
over it again this clarity and
strictness means that we can look at a
function and be comfortable what it can
and can't do and therefore write and
refactor code more confidently there are
no surprises or black magic allowed at
all so the nice thing about programming
in Haskell is that Haskell is a
functional first language other
functional languages come with a baggage
of the non FP platform that they're
built on so for example Scala doesn't
have mutually recursive functions
because the JVM doesn't support tail
calls and this means that recursion
which is a key functional technique
needs to be handled with care and
scholar and often worked around with a
technique called trampolining to make
sure you don't blow the stack in F sharp
it doesn't unfortunately support high
kind of types because the dotnet generic
system doesn't support them and
Haskell's doesn't doesn't have cloves
and suffer from either these problems
because
it's run time was designed with
functional programming in mind and it
doesn't have either of these two
limitations
Haskell's runtime also includes a
special garbage collector that's built
to handle the generation and collection
of a lot of garbage and because
everything is immutable and hassle you
can imagine that lots of intermediate
garbage values are created during the
execution of a program
so Haskell's garbage collector can take
advantage of some of the guarantees that
function purity provides and it uses
techniques that ensure that lots of
garbage that you create in a short
amount of time that you then don't use
is discarded and cleaned up with a very
small cost now one of the advantages of
using a language like F sharp is that
you can lean on the entire of the.net
ecosystem for libraries which is really
good but the downside of this is that
often you'll be dealing with oo style
libraries that love their mutability and
where you'd actually rather be dealing
with an FP style library that uses
functional types like option which is
the maybe in f-sharp and you know uses
immutable types in Haskell all the
libraries are functional and immutable
so you don't have to compromise the
downside being that sometimes there
isn't a library for that thing that you
want now the learning curve of Haskell
is one of its disadvantages learning a
language like F sharp is easier because
it is a hybrid language with oo which
lets you lean on your previous knowledge
as you adopt and getting used to the new
functional bits and because Haskell
enforces purity and immutability and is
a lazy language writing real programs
and it can be quite different to using
other languages and this means there can
be a fair bit of upfront learning that
you need to do in order to learn how to
do things in a pure functional way
however I don't think we should be
surprised that this is the case and I
think it's unfair to compare it in the
same way that we might compare a c-sharp
developer picking up JavaScript
well c-sharp and JavaScript do have
their differences the syntax is still C
based there's still imperative mutable
strict evaluation languages Haskell is
much more different as we've seen it's
not C based it's functional it's
immutable and it has lazy evaluation
so naturally things are going to be
different another perspective on this is
that the learning functional programming
properly is actually easier in high
school because the whole language is
geared for it and
libraries and examples are always done
in a pure functional style and of course
because pure FP is quite different to
normal imperative programming it takes a
little bit of learning to adjust but
you'll come out with a small sound
understanding of FP principles at the
end now real Haskell programs require to
pick up many different functional
concepts such as functors applicatives
monads of which there are many io state
may be either reader and writer and many
others
there's also mono transformers and
foldable and a whole bunch of others so
there's lots of new things to learn but
all of them are helpful abstractions
that soon become as familiar to you as
the strategy pattern or the observer
pattern is you know oh now don't try to
reach for your oo abstractions when you
are trying to write FP code instead
think about the problem that they're
originally designed to solve and think
of and find out how that problem is
solved using FP techniques instead so
for example in FP dependency injection
is just function composition it's
important to realize that getting over
high schools learning curve is
absolutely an achievable task while
concepts like monads and functors sounds
scary you don't actually need to be a
genius or a math person to understand
them like I don't know any maths I went
to Johns quantum computing stuff and he
blew my mind with math there are plenty
of good tutorials online and books to
read that explain what these concepts
are and why you choose to use them and
I'll recommend a few at the end these
abstractions aren't just academic and
learning them is an investment that does
pay off as they allow you to write
declarative code that has minimal
plumbing and that expresses intention
more clearly because you've extracted
that plumbing away from it Haskell is a
very deep language don't measure your
progress by seeing how far you are away
from knowing that everything that
Haskell has to offer instead focus on
whether you need to know you know what
you need to know in order to solve a
problem that you haven't had there are
corners of Haskell that you'll probably
never venture into so am I saying if you
want to do functional programming you
should always use from you should always
use Haskell if you want to be a real
functional programmer no I'm not saying
that I would never say that Haskell
should be
use in all situations and I don't think
I'd say that about any specific
technology unfortunately the world is
not black and white it would be simpler
if it was and your personal requirements
might be different to mine if you don't
feel ready to go whole hog on functional
programming purity and immutability then
you'd like to stay in familiar dotnet or
Java and both F sharp and Scala are
competent languages and I do encourage
you to go off and use them with that
said I think you should consider Haskell
if you've done some FP before in one of
these hybrid languages and you're loving
it but you're getting frustrated when
you have to cross over into that oo
mutable part of the language if you've
seen how useful immutability and purity
are and you want more of that
then Haskell will make you a very happy
person Haskell is quite different but if
you're willing to learn new things it's
extremely rewarding and absolutely
within reach for those who have the
patience to learn and if correctness and
clarity of paramount importance to you
then Haskell is a really good choice
because you can express your intention
in a clear declarative style so what
sort of applications are good to write
in high school well anytime you want to
do some data pausing or processing high
schools a really great choice
it's declarative style and great pausing
libraries make that sort of problem a
pleasure to solve any program with
complex algorithms is going to be really
good to ride in Haskell because you can
write DSL is very easily that make that
code understandable and it's type system
and really good testing capabilities
make ensuring correctness easy programs
that consume Web Services or our web
services are well supported in high
school there are really good libraries
available for dealing with HTTP and JSON
and scripts and command line programs
also really good to write in high school
scripts can often go out of control over
time they start out small and then end
up getting really large but Haskell
static typing and it's type of inference
helps keep your scripts correct but
still concise Haskell also has a really
good command-line argument puzzle
library it's probably the best I've ever
use and we probably shouldn't be
surprised because Haskell's really good
at pausing however Haskell isn't suited
for everything just yet so sequel
databases are surprising an annoying
weak point
if you're wanting to use Postgres and
you can use Postgres then it'll be fine
because there are some really good
libraries working for Postgres but major
commercial databases like sequel server
and oracle they have some support but
apparently it's not perfect which is a
shame
gooey desktop applications are also not
Haskell's forte there are some libraries
to help you write like gtk apps but you
can fade it forget about WPF and zamel
and let's face it if you're writing
something new these days it's probably
for the web anyway so the state of
Haskell ecosystem document that Gabriele
Gonzalez keeps up-to-date on github is a
good place to look to see whether your
particular problem is well suited to
Haskell so that's how I know about
sequel databases because I went into
there and it says immature and it gives
some reasoning as well
so who else use Haskell who else in
industry uses Haskell in production well
the highest profile use that I know of
is it Facebook where they use Haskell to
fight spam they developed a hacks old
data access framework that allows them
to quickly and efficiently access the
data they need to figure out whether
post to spam or not and then they write
these rules in Haskell Facebook have
done a number of presentations about
this and you're able to find recordings
on it if you just google for it I know
seek has a couple of teams that work in
high school to do some data processing
and analysis as well as internal api's
it was at seek that I got my production
high school experience there's also a
helium and circuit hub if you want to
look up what they do now if you want to
learn Haskell I highly recommend the
Haskell programming from first
principles book otherwise known as the
Haskell book it starts from the
beginning and it goes into sufficient
detail and it doesn't gloss over things
and it has exercises along the way that
you can do if you want to cement these
concepts in the head in your head
because often you can stare at them and
then you go I still don't get it and it
wasn't isn't until you actually do it a
few times then it clicks so having those
exercises put out before you really
helps there's also learn you at Haskell
for a great good so if you want to read
something for free online you can have a
look at that but you know if you've got
a if you've got some spare cash I really
do recommend buying a Haskell book it's
a much better resource
there's also maybe Haskell with some
pragmatic examples about why you should
care about FP and Haskell Haskell
subreddit
obviously Stack Overflow and there's
some
haskell tagged post on the FP complete
blog which have some good practical
advice for production high school as
well so wrapping up we took a lightning
tour of many of the features that
Haskell offers us developers to make
reading writing and maintaining correct
code easier Haskell's strong static
typing system allows us to refactor
fearlessly by getting the compiler to
check our correctness type inference and
huugle make it easy to work with that
type system and find the functions that
we need some types help us model our
alternatives explicitly freeing us from
among other things the tyranny of
unexpected null references new types
help us model our domain types more
explicitly and provide clarity and make
that type system work for us or for the
runtime cost of zero immutable
immutability and purity help us write
simpler more understandable code that
can be used in concurrent systems safely
and function purity and along with
Haskell's easy support of value
semantics and property testing make
casting our code for correctness easier
and laziness helps us write more
declarative code that will still execute
efficiently but we do need to keep an
eye out for those space leaks and
haskell makes it easy to write fast
scalable concurrent code on its green
threading system because it natively
supports asynchronously I think a
synchrony and makes testing concurrent
libraries and has those powerful
concurrent libraries and of course
immutability and concurrency go very
very well together so hopefully you've
enjoyed your peek into the haskell
universe and you can see how it can help
you as a developer and now you want to
go find out some more rest assured that
I've only touched lightly the surface of
what Haskell is about even though I've
kind of ranted for Buckett an hour so I
put these slides up on github so the
link is up there please take a picture
or memorize it if you've got a great
memory I'm also on Twitter so feel free
to contact me there if you see me around
the conference just look out for the
bright green jumper and you find me in a
crowd I'm happy to take any questions
although I think I'm a little bit over
time so I am actually going to the
dotnet rocks interview just after this
so and I believe they do do a Q&A so
maybe come have a chat to me quickly
after that and then I've got
up there and maybe come and ask me live
in front of an audience a question
embarrass me or something thank you
[Applause]